تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مشهدا
غير مالوف لاكوام من الثلوج في شوارع
الباحه جنوبيه السعوديه بعد هطول الامطار
المصحوبه بالبرد واظهرت مقاطع فيديو
متداوله جرافات تعمل على ازاله الثلوج
المتراكمه في الشوارع نتابع
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مشهدا
لطيفا لاحد المعتمرين وهو يقوم بتدليك
عمال النظافه في الحرم المكي لتخفيف التعب
عنهم
من قال ان روبوتات لا تتعب لقطه تظهر
البوتان من شركه اجلتي وهو يسقط من التعب
بعد عشرين ساعه متواصله من العمل في حمل
البضائع عن الارفف هل هو التعب ام
البطاريه نشاهد
[موسيقى]
بعدما اثار مقطع فيديو الجدل في العراق
يظهر شابا يتحرش بفتاه في نهار رمضان في
مدينه البصره اعلنت الشرطه اعتقال المتهم
واتخاذ جميع الاجراءات القانونيه بحقه
[موسيقى]
بعد ان ضجت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي حول
المتحرش الذي حاول التحرش بمواطن عراقيه
في محافظه البصره سارعت قياده شرطه البصره
وقسم مكافحه اجرام البصره بامره العقيد
محمد الوائلي
بالقبض على المتهم
وحالته الى المحكمه
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات